this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
well good afternoon every
and welcome to the Thursday december six
2012 session in our series on green
technologies and transportation and
today is the ultimate session in this
series I'm Richard Dasher I direct the
u.s. Asia Technology Management Center
and we produce the series we also want
to recognize additional financial
assistance from the Allen minor
foundation and Sunbridge partners we've
got some refreshments back in the back
today and we hope you'll join us in
meeting with our speaker and meeting
with each other that's some of the best
parts of these sessions and thanks to
Alan for the support that allows us to
do that for students who are registered
for credit the scheduled exam time for
this course if we had an exam would be
Thursday December 13 from 1215 to 3 15
in the afternoon this means that lets
make Thursday December 13 the deadline
for all of the materials that you need
to finish up in order to get credit for
the course that includes any kind of
make up papers that you might be writing
as well as your set your summaries for
today's session so make sure you get
everything to me by email by December 13
oh I'm very happy that we can welcome
mr. lou thompson to be with us today and
talk about what the US should learn from
the asian high-speed rail experience lou
is probably uniquely qualified to give
this presentation he has a bachelor of
science from MIT and an MBA from Harvard
and then he worked around at some
companies and was had several jobs with
what used to be called the federal
railway administration and this was back
in the late 1970s until the mid 1980s
including being the director of the
northeast corridor improvement project
during that time and for 1986 until 2003
he
was railways advisor to the World Bank
and so we were talking about comparing
business trips Oh before the session
started today from 2003 Lou has been a
principal of a consulting firm Thompson
galen ssin and associates he's also
currently a member of the board of
directors of the railway Research
Foundation and he's a member of the peer
review panel for the California High
Speed Rail Authority so we're very
delighted that Lou can come and talk to
us about railways and what we should
learn thank you for coming thank you
Richard ah a ground rule it doesn't
bother me if you have a question to ask
it whenever we get to it then one of the
things I dislike about lectures is
having to wait until the end and then
I've forgotten my question or if I pose
it it doesn't make any sense and in the
final context of the lecture so feel
free if you won this is not that larger
group feel free if you want to ask a
question I want to do several things
first the topic that I was asked to talk
about is Asian high-speed experience and
experience and I'm going to talk about
Asia as if it were China Taiwan Japan
Korea and India that's kind of an
incomplete definition many people would
think but these do represent the major
railway countries in Asia and in fact
especially China Japan and India the
major railway companies in the world so
it's a worthwhile sample to use in
comparing with the United States I want
to talk partly about comparative roles
in scales of the systems the problem is
that that each of us has in his mind a
view of something called a railway many
of you had a children's book and there
was a steam locomotive or Thomas the
Tank Engine and you still kind of have
that image in your head well railways
are very different they're not the same
even within the context of technology or
services so first I want to set the
scene for you of why
these railways are different and why the
lessons that you learn the technology
they use the way in which they approach
problems can be quite different then I'd
like to talk a little bit about
structure and Finance of the comparative
structure and Finance of the system
because structure and Finance and then
indeed the institutions in the policy or
what make technology either work or not
work technology doesn't exist all by
itself it doesn't exist in isolation and
some kinds of technologies work in one
set of structures or finance and they
don't work in others so it's important
to know what the what the context is in
which these issues are being addressed
first let's look at passengers carried
and as you can see I think you asked by
the way looks like zero it isn't but
it's kind of close I've got shown
high-speed rail in green and then all
passengers and the orange color the US
doesn't even show I mean it's there I
put the numbers but but on this scale
you can't even find it the u.s. is not a
railway passenger country by comparison
Japan and India are enormous numbers of
passengers enormous numbers of
passengers China is lower Korea's lower
taiwan is lower high-speed roll compared
with the total conventional passenger
system the high speed role in numbers of
passengers is just not that large in
most of these countries what the railway
is really doing where you see the high
number of passengers is it's hauling
suburban passengers or short haul
passengers and high-speed rail is only a
part and in many cases of minority part
of even their passenger business yes you
this happens to be 2010 the year 2010
sure I'm having trouble with zeros
that's 800 million passenger train it's
eight billion eight billion passenger
trips eight million guys okay billion
passenger trips in Japan that's what 40
times the population not surprising no
suburban includes conventional railways
not the Metro conventional railways and
the high-speed railways so the traffic
of the six jrs is what this includes
passenger kilometers is another measure
of the same thing this is the product of
the number of passengers times the
length of their trip this is the more
conventional measure and transportation
of output and you get somewhat the same
picture although things or things shift
a little bit again the u.s. is
negligible we do have some high-speed
rail it's called the axela that Amtrak
operates between new york and and
Washington and Boston it does reach 150
miles an hour for about 20 miles of the
five four hundred fifty mile trip so
it's sort of high speed rail but it's
it's tiny China reports no statistics so
I just can't tell you about their high
speed rail system I what you get is
reports of accidents occasionally or
their construction program but I know
nothing about the numbers of passengers
or passenger kilometers India again is
enormous in terms of passenger
kilometers much larger than the other
countries but no high-speed rail no
high-speed rail in India and then you
can see how Korea and Taiwan fit into
this comparison but even by comparison
with Korea and Taiwan the u.s. rail
passenger services is tiny really small
and that will see why that's important a
little bit later to put this in a
different context now I turn it around
and tell you about the freight service
around
which of the railways that really matter
in freight service and now the u.s.
matters a lot wait the u.s. is a freight
system it really isn't a passenger
system we have a few passenger trains
running around but the u.s. is a freight
system China is an enormous freight
system as well as an enormous passenger
system China is the largest railway in
the world measured by the total traffic
that the railway carries and it has been
the fastest growing for many years India
is significant Taiwan Korea Japan Japan
doesn't really carry very much Freight
kind of residual from from many earlier
years this puts it a different way what
I've shown here is the percentage of the
total traffic of the railway that is
passenger service so it's passenger
kilometres divided by the sum of
passenger kilometers in tunk long it's a
rough measure but it's a good indication
for you of is this a freight railroad or
a passenger rail road for the most part
oh point three percent in the United
States as passenger service oh point
three percent China is twenty-four
percent passenger service characteristic
of European EU countries is thirty to
sixty percent something like that in
that range Taiwan is ninety-five percent
passenger Japan as 92% passengers so
they're very different systems and the
management is trying to do different
things and that the mentality required
the ideas the objectives of a passenger
railway and especially a high-speed
railway passenger railway are utterly
different than a freight railway so when
we when we think about what lessons are
there and how would they be transferred
or learned you have to keep in mind that
that they some lessons aren't relevant
maybe it'd be nice to learn them but we
can't do anything about
question sure why did the systems
develop within such a different way in
the u.s. railway passenger railway
traffic really declined with the advent
of the airplanes in the 60s is kind of
my sense ah much more with the advent of
the interstate highway system ah both of
those things killed rail passenger
service in the United States but the
other thing that killed rail passenger
service in the United States was it's
not profitable but there's also so our
system has always been operated by
private companies who operate things
they can money make money with and they
don't operate things they can't make
money with and their mentality was
driven by perfectly valid profit motive
in our system but that was Japanese
national railways prior to I'll had the
sub getting ahead of myself but to
answer your question no prior to its
privatization in 1987 Japanese national
railways was losing 15 billion dollars a
year 15 billion dollars a year and they
had a debt of something like 250 billion
dollars Wow so when your passenger
oriented when there is a public service
objective in mind you have one one way
of approaching a problem and you
recognize one set of measures of capital
efficiency you invest differently
because you're measuring your rate of
return differently if at all so the
approach to all of these things
investment management traffic marketing
they're all dependent on these variables
of what kind of service am I providing
and what what kind of market am i
serving and it radically affects the way
they think let's talk a little bit about
structure and Finance of these systems
because it is quite different the u.s.
system is vertically integrated by
vertically integrated I mean that the
operator owns the tracks they're
integrated together and one company
controls the use of both the services
and the tracks we recognize Amtrak as
being a separated operator that runs
throughout the system and pays for the
use of the track but the freight is
integrated vertically integrated with
the track we have nine so-called class
one freight railroads these are variants
with revenue more than about 370 million
dollars a year we have something like
500 short line railroads or one kind of
the other remnants of old railroads mine
pop operations whatever and then the
freight railroads are private but Amtrak
is publicly owned and it is publicly
financed that's the way we do this in
Japan the high-speed rail is in it
vertically integrated with the track as
always has been the conventional
passenger systems these are the narrow
gauge so call narrow gauge system Cape
gauge system is also vertically
integrated but the freight railway is
like Amtrak the freight railway operates
on the entire system and pays trackage
fees for it there's six passenger major
passenger I was there a lot of private
railways in Japan that don't figure in
this calculation something like thirty
percent of the kilometres of track in
Japan have never been part of jnr or the
major Japanese railway company there's
only one freight company the old jnr was
publicly owned and it carried all kinds
of public burdens for example after
World War Two they were required to hire
returning veterans simply as a way of
giving them a job so the objectives of
the company were not only private or
even passenger service they were they
had public objectives ah three of the
new jrs are private they were sold the
shares were sold I wish I had bought
them when they were in during their IPO
some of them are done bare
well they're profitable they're stable
they do very well as private companies
the state three of them are so public
and they're they're subsidized by an
interesting device a trust fund was
established for them and the and the
earnings of the trust fund are used to
subsidize the operation of the three
smaller jrs so that they are not
subsidized every year by appropriation
they have a stable income to depend on
the freight service the government has
has yet to figure out what to do with it
it's a very difficult to operate it's
not profitable but at the same time
they're not quite clear what they should
do with it financing is a mix of public
money private money mostly for the
private companies but public money mixed
with private money for investment and
for example new lines that the
government wants to build and there is a
balance of public and private profits to
be earned China's moffat monolithic one
railway one company one size fits all
and it's fully public although they mor
the Ministry of Railways of China which
is the official name of this and note
that it's a ministry not even a
state-owned enterprise it's a ministry
it has done some private borrowing
people assume that the bonds of the
railway are backed by the railway and by
the government we'll we'll see yeah yeah
sure so there there are some private
bonds are any is direct taxes our taxes
going directly to help subsidize
operations no no okay where a is quote
profitable okay Turin's revenues in
excess of its operating costs may be
significantly in excess if it's a prank
on which is kind of amazing considering
the fares are very cheap wait a min
China d'affaires are not so low and
compared to India for example fears are
derisive low
and China the passenger fares on average
or roughly like the freight fares in
India there are about one third the
freight fares and in the United States
there are 15 times the freight fair so
if you want a sense of that the way in
which they earn or donor and money but
Korea it's monolithic they have
separated high-speed rail tracks as they
do in China there's only one company
Korean railways and it's wholly public
Taiwan is very interesting because the
high-speed rail system in Taiwan was
built as a private concession the
government awarded a concession to a
private consortium and they promised
they would build a system they would
operate it and they would not ask for
any government money then work out that
way but they got well into it and then
for a lot of reasons some of which were
not their fault political interference
they ran out of money and the government
has had to buy about fifteen percent the
twenty percent of the company oh but
that's all they have two companies the
THS are Taiwan high-speed rail and then
the taiwan railways and it's mostly
private for a high-speed rail public for
the conventional services and then by
comparison india is kind of the the most
monolithic the most public the least
exposed to any kind of private finance
or private structure Indian Railways is
immense amul they are symbol is the
elephant and they're right institutions
and policies for high-speed rail in
these countries differ also we I don't
know what this thing did to my
typography is interesting anyways what
happens when you type of EC of
PowerPoint and put it onto a mac
aha okay well no way you can see what I
was trying to say okay Amtrak is our
only intercity passenger company in fact
it has a monopoly on intercity passenger
services that was part of the deal under
which it was created there are some new
state level agencies for high-speed rail
like California that have been created
they have unclear mandates their
financing is not stable or sufficient
they and they have little or no
expertise to really get the job done by
comparison with jnr which could design
everything construct everything manage
everything they had a clear mandate say
here juniors have our private
institutions they have clear mandates
they have deep experience they know
exactly what they're doing here in the
US government support for high-speed
rail is about that thick it's this broad
but about that thick that is the Obama
administration has said it likes high
speed rail it provided some money in the
American rebuilding and Rehabilitation
Act but there is no real government
program in existence there's a policy
that would be nice to have one but in
this budget environment it has to
compete with every other thing that
wants money unlike the interstate
highway program in the u.s. that had a
stated amount of gasoline tax they knew
what the money was it was dependable
they could plan they could manage around
that and the interstate highway system
which took 35 or 40 years to get built
got built it was planned and built and
it may be one of the most successful
large infrastructure projects ever done
anywhere very little corruption very
little diversion of money except that it
there was a problem we don't need to
discuss that but
basically it started as an interstate
program it ended up being a series of
commuter highways that's where the money
is on the interstate highway program as
on the computer highways and not on the
interstate part of the highway okay mor
has a very clear mandate they have deep
experience they have real implementation
capability in fact maybe too much when
and China is interesting to work in
China because they're fierce debates
about what's going to be done but once
that has been settled it is done thinner
amazingly fast possibly too fast there's
not much public information available
about who's doing what and some of the
high speed rail in China was actually
built not for high-speed rail but in
order to get traffic off the freight
railway the freight railway in China is
the railway in China in general has a
densest traffic pattern of any railway
in the world it's approximately three
times the average of the United States
so passenger rail and freight railway
don't coexist on the same track very
well and high-speed rail on freight
tracks is impossible for a lot of
reasons so when the Chinese began to
want to speed up their passenger trains
they had to get them off the freight
tracks in order to improve the freight
capacity Korea Korean always has a clear
mandate and full expertise the program
pace has been deliberate they've not
been in a hurry they've gotten and
they've also operated pieces this system
where the Thai speed train runs fast
when it can and then slow when it has to
they've been able to link it with the
system and organically grow the
government support has been clear and
pretty stable taiwan as i said was
intended to be private but it didn't
work out that way the government was too
ambitious I think about this confession
and they may not have reached a stable
solution even now they assumed away a
lot of this is another problem you need
to think about they
they didn't know how to do what they
tried to do concessional high-speed
railway de novo is a very very
complicated problem had not been done in
Taiwan hasn't been done in the United
States either but they took it on and
they're gradually getting there but they
haven't gotten it there yet indian
railways as i said is slow and
bureaucratic technically they can build
and operate railroads but they have no
experience with high-speed rail they do
have some plans for I speed rail in
India but I think their priority right
now is more on the freight side building
a dedicated freight railway then and
that's what they call the golden
quadrilateral rather than building high
speed rail so what do we learn from all
of this well some broad lessons first of
all as I've said the technology is a lot
of fun i love it i really enjoy the
pictures of the high-speed trains and
mount fuji in the background or whatever
that's a lot of fun but that really
isn't the problem as far as i am
concerned there are plenty of countries
that know how to do the technology
france japan excellent china probably
others the technology exists it does not
exist to run 220 miles an hour that has
been done in testing conditions but day
in day out and Revenue Service 220 miles
an hour is stretching the state of the
art by about 30 miles an hour and as you
know energy where all of those things
are exponential on high-speed railways
so we need a much clearer understanding
of what's the public role here and
what's the private role here I will
assert that no high-speed railway has
ever been built purely with private
money there are some that are owned now
privately the Japanese national railways
those they weren't built with private
money and the process of
privatizing the company it still isn't
clear how much debt was transferred what
equity ended up here and therefore
whether these quote profitable
high-speed rail companies are really
earning high rates of return that's the
definition of the investment we in the
US have almost no experience with
private operation of passenger trains
strange but it's true I used to say we
were the last bastion of railroad
socialism we always have operated our
commuter trains and our passenger trains
with a public entity and we don't have
any experience with private sector
companies operating these for-profit we
have very little or no experience with
ppps in passenger rail service we do
have some experience with what I would
call a management contract caltrain here
is a management contract but it calls
for very little investment on the part
of the operator very little marketing
expertise very little of the the thing
you would expect to see to make a
private sector kind of venture
successful it's just I'm hiring you to
run my railway in the following way what
we also don't do in the United States
and we could learn from Japan especially
Japan is how to measure public benefits
as opposed to private benefits and then
how to have the public sector pay for
its benefits and the private sector
paper it's through revenues and
operating costs we simply still don't do
that well in the United States we're
okay if the private sector can do it
fully we're okay if the public's sort of
if the public sector has to do it we at
least we know how to organize these and
manage them what we don't know how to do
is manage those that have a leg in both
both pots that we don't know how to do
and we could certainly learn there what
another lesson from Japan and China the
others is that they're the critical role
of being able to do stable planning and
financing environment what we do in the
u.s. right now for I speed rail is we
have a 50-year project but one year
financing and next year maybe we'll have
it maybe we won't or maybe there'll be
an argument and the Republicans will do
this and the Democrats will do this we
will have to forego that year's funding
you can't do this kind of project that
way asian countries have been able to
plan stabili and then fund stay boy and
that is we did it on the interstate
highway program yes so we know how to do
it but we need to apply that lesson to
high-speed rail if we really want
high-speed rail as I said about
managerial capability it doesn't exist
in the United States it just doesn't
exist and it takes years to build this
kind of capability it's a long long time
and a lot of experience and a lot of
mistakes overall I think my experience
in Japan was that plus or minus they
knew exactly what they were doing they
knew what the demand was going to be
they knew what the cost was going to be
they knew how to manage it and they knew
how to integrate what they were doing
into the national and the local level
transportation planning so they didn't
build a high-speed railway station and
then suddenly find out there was no mass
transport to take the people to her from
the station they had a picture of the
entire system and mine in the US the
Federal Railroad Administration which is
handling the high speed rail money
doesn't talk to the federal
transportation administration which
which handles the local transportation
money's not that they don't like each
other it's just that there's no they
don't talk because there are different
agencies and there's no require
that they talk to each other so you can
easily have situations here in which in
California maybe an example in which the
high-speed rail will arrive in a sea
only to find out that there's no bus
service to serve the station or no no
trolleys or no transit or know anything
else other than possibly a gigantic
parking and that's a lesson that the
Asians all of them have learned and they
all of them employ and one that we
really should employ here so that's kind
of my distillation of what we should
learn there probably other lessons but
those are the ones I think of the most
important so that's it thank you very
much for your comments so this is great
cause this doesn't leave a lot of time
for discussion I want to ask you with
regard to the kind of greening of
Railways what are some of the trends
that you see that are happening either
here in Asia to make them more
environmentally friendly things that
just come to the top of your head well
two things really one of them one of
them is that if you look at the energy
concert consumption for the high-speed
railways in Japan at the same speed it's
been going like that for years so the at
the same speed they've been able to
decrease the energy consumption and
therefore increase the energy efficiency
of the trains but more than that I think
it's a mistake to look at high speed
rail in terms of energy or co2 or
emissions because that that isn't really
where the benefits are and that's there
but that isn't really where the benefits
are the benefits I think in the long run
have much more to do with with planning
of these of land and the way in which it
is managed so that in California we
could have people grouped in our cities
and not scatter all out through
environmentally sensitive areas or
places where people really shouldn't be
living we it permits you to organize the
society operates much more efficiently
and effectively then then then we get
with just a highway model as we know but
it goes back to the question of how do
you define the public benefits what he
include within your computation of a
public benefit how much is it worth to
be able to organize people to live in a
particular way efficiently in a city
rather than scattered you know allow Los
Angeles what is what is that really
worth to us and and we're not good at it
and I'm not sure that we're good at
assigning a value to it either so all
the more of the interstate highway
system is an amazing kind of rare
example in the US of a long term huge
scale project that worked but even there
the interstate highway system is very
interesting because it's an example of a
program that started out right and then
it kind of got away from us because if
you look at the original planning
documents for interstate highway system
it has wonderful lines and then there's
a circle around the city the original
plans didn't have these beltway's or
they always but it didn't have the urban
links and the things that went right
into the middle of the city and just
bulldoze away neighborhoods and other
things because people wanted to be able
to drive to work as the program gathered
momentum and money the the objective
shifted or the way in which the money
was spent shifted and and that which was
going to be an interstate program mostly
for long-haul transportation measured by
money and measured by passengers not by
Freight but by passengers became much
more of an urban highway system with
with interurban links than an inner
urban system with okay and so I've got
one more question then it will open up
the floor you and I got to meet each
other at the beginning of October in
this program where a lot of talk was
made of maglev the plans for junior
central to develop this you know
maglev track all the way from Tokyo to
Nagoya by way of Nagano what's next do
you see major new technologies like that
transforming rail traffic yet again well
backup rail halls freight okay immense
amounts afraid the linkage between 10
kilometers in GDP is very clear and it's
very well established 10 kilometers care
for life lessons okay the linkage
between GDP and passenger kilometers is
much less clear it's certainly you can
argue that GDP drives passenger
kilometers but it's much harder to argue
the other way around that we didn't have
all those passenger kilometers we
wouldn't have that GDP so it's a
different different question about what
do people use passenger transport for
and why would they want the right of
railway why would they want to run at
high speed railway and why would they
want to ride it super high-speed rail
one if you look at the service capable I
brought this chart but I didn't if you
look at the service capabilities in
terms of trip time total trip time you
find that that the automobile dominates
450 miles no matter what you do as long
as there's no congestion when one source
congestion then mass transit does very
well for short trips between 50 and
let's say 200 miles conventional rail is
just as fast as high-speed rail because
the speed doesn't really do much for you
between let's say 150 miles and 500
miles high speed rail begins to that
that's its competitive zone it's sweet
spot because it's faster than low speed
rail but it's but it has but it's still
faster than than the airplane which
though it is cruises faster can't make
up for the delays in the airport now and
taken out everything by the way
one of the main competitive factors in
rail versus here for short haul trips is
security at the airport if security of
the airport were ever fixed air travel
would suddenly become a lot more
competitive for shredder haul trips than
at any rate beyond 500 miles there's no
calculation you can make about high
speed rail that says high speed rail is
faster than the airplane it just isn't
but if you have an enormous volume of
people yeah Tokyo to Osaka for example
where the volume to us is almost imagine
then then the investments in these
extremely highly high-speed highly
efficient high-capacity systems begin to
make sense but but I am sure that Jer or
central is not thinking about you know
Tokyo 250 miles out for the oven pilot
that are going to buy really long haul
very high speed now where would you go
from here well there's always been
discussion of short takeoff and landing
aircraft on the one hand and there have
been discussion of things like
high-speed trains in evacuated tubes
that's been discussed and in fact those
who actually those were at people were
actually transported by pneumatic tubes
before the turn of the century have you
ever seen these male have you seen the
mail systems or there are they bill
delivery well there were still where
actual people offers that you know when
you ended up at the other end of the
state hopefully in one piece but you
know the technology is there the
question is is it a solution in search
of a problem what problem is it trying
to solve and you know it gets harder and
harder to make the case against airline
travel when the distance gets beyond say
four or five hundred miles okay so the
US would be it would be relevant for
things like the Northeast Corridor the
North case I might be one
Washington to Boston uh-huh yeah but but
it's not really relevant for Washington
to Philadelphia okay okay but another
difference between between the u.s. and
certainly Japan is that our distances
here are so much larger that's not true
of China but certainly of us in Japan
the distances that we travel routinely
are much further than they do in Japan
go ahead I saw your hand first just for
the rails for boat I see me well and and
are their cars interchangeable for both
high speed and regular okay that's good
question and the answer is no or
sometimes maybe better the Japanese
system was three feet 6 inches gauge the
whole system with three foot six hundred
they decided that they could not run
high speed trains on narrow gauge track
that there was not enough inherent
stability in the track to do it so when
they built the Shinkansen the new lines
their their so-called standard gauge
four feet eight and a half inches so
that the Japanese and concen cannot
travel on the narrow gauge tracks and
vice versa there's some very specialized
gauge changing stuff but it's not very
important so if you want to go some
wildness and content and then somewhere
on the narrow gate system you have to
change or the station if it works but
the genius of the tgv in France was that
they realized that you could travel in a
high-speed train on a low speed track so
they built the high-speed segments
outside the cities and then into the
cities is the existing conventional
track it's all standard gauge and then
extensions flights a Lyon to to Geneva
those are on the regular track those are
not done on the high-speed track so that
you can take advantage of the high speed
links in the system but you can also
operate off the system as well without
having to get off the train and change
tracks
china is all standard gauge Taiwan's all
standard gauge Korea's all standard
gauge Japan is a mixture India is broad
gauge 5 feet 6 inches no one's ever
built ice be trained on that we assume
they could the u.s. is all standard
gauge Thank You Lou I had the pleasure
of writing high-speed rail in at least
two countries maybe as much as four and
so the benefits I think are very obvious
in reference to your last slide over
here what the u.s. can learn it along
with a parallel with health care is
there a willingness in the u.s. to look
at successful projects and other
countries because my sense is that's
that's a right here in your many times
to overcome I'm not sure I understand
the question well if you see a
successful solution is there the
willingness to sort of look at that is
the first blueprint in the US let me ask
the question is there some reason why we
don't bite somebody else's technology
and just use it why do we invent it
ourselves benefit from the knowledge
that the pre-existing knowledge
generally speaking the proposers for
high speed systems in the United States
have been supported by either the French
or the Japanese and sometimes the
Germans so it's a it's in fact we've not
in the u.s. attempted to invent our own
high-speed technology we did in the 70s
we were trying to invent are in fact
maglev some of the first bank life stuff
was done in the United States but but
very quickly realized that when the
Japanese have eight billion passengers
and we have 32 million more 23-minute
why in the world would we want to invent
technology that they're much better at
than we are so I think the US has
actually been fairly good at realizing
aerospace companies in the contrary
notwithstanding at realizing that we
just don't need to do this ourselves we
can buy it from somebody let me ask a
follow-up on that so from what I know
which is very little California
essential
we put out the high speed rail project
sort of to a bid to these different
technologies right to the dome that is
not really in fact one of our concerns
has been that the the high-speed rail
authority has has tried to stay
technology neutral as long as they can
now the argument for that of course is
that as long as your technology neutral
do you maintain competition as soon as
you say we're going to use Japanese
technology than a number of bidders
available for all kinds of things goes
poof or French technology same thing
happens that's fine but at some point a
decision on who's going to operate the
system has to be made that operator is
almost certainly going to be a
concessionaire from Japan or from France
or from Germany or wherever and they're
going to be very uncomfortable if
they're Japanese driving French trains
they're just using French technology and
etc they don't know how to use it not
familiar with it so there's going to be
a point at which choices have to be made
and they're going to have to learn the
US market they they certainly are that
the problem is that the traditional
especially Japanese approach to the US
market has been fire-and-forget will
build trains there and will sell them
but we don't want to have anything to do
with operating the system so we're happy
to sell you rolling stock and then you
know you take it from there the emphasis
in most concessions is we want you to
operate the system for us bring the
rolling stock do the marketing bring the
ticketing bring the other bunch of work
and higher yes hire us employees would
be silly to bring Japanese to drive
trains in the US but but but but but
when your expertise and run the system
for us no this is a really that's a
different that's a different issue and a
difference well it's a really
interesting thing because railways are
us in some way a service business right
I mean they are a service business well
honey I don't the emphasis on the word
business yeah what's no point of a
high-speed railway which is competing
with Airlines why would why why wouldn't
you realize that it's a business the
airline certainly do and the airline
marketing and service patterns and the
way in which they operate is intensely
competitive and the way you survive is
understanding the business not how do I
run trains but what's the business of
hauling people and you don't generally
speaking public authorities don't do
that very well you need a concession to
operator with operating marketing
commercial expertise to do it I'm asking
too many questions I saw a hand over
here that I wanted to okay then I missed
it jim was it okay did I did I
understand you to say that 600 miles is
not a really efficient competition with
their alliance or now it's under 600
miles the airlines will always prevail
on trip time unless there's some unusual
circumstances 500 or so is B is the
outer end of the possibility of a
high-speed train competing with air much
beyond that there's always going to be
of course if you had a 600 I would much
rather grab because I can get there
faster than flying by the time I grabbed
the airport find parking then I get the
Los Angeles and I have like take a taxi
and traffic I mean this restaurant you
make you make a really important point
at which came up earlier and that is
don't think of high-speed rail in terms
of numbers of people is competing with
Airlines it's actually competing with
the highway you could take their only
seven to eight million people who fly a
year from all of these San Francisco
airports to and from all over the los
angeles airport so that's all that's it
and so if you are on a percent of the
market there's still something like one
fourth of the projected demand
that they have right now and track the
way it operates right now has nearly a
hundred percent well has a hundred
percent of the airline market from
Washington to Philadelphia Baltimore to
Philadelphia Baltimore to New York and
it has almost all of the airline market
from Washington to New York already so
and that's 150 miles an hour for 20
miles and an average speed of 80 miles
an hour so what would a high-speed train
accomplished under those circumstances
well it's not going to get any more
airline passenger maybe it'll get people
out of the car and maybe it will
generate induce demand but it's not
going to compete that well with arrow to
run the high-speed rail from the
outskirts of La to the San Francisco
area then come down the caltrain tracks
at regular speed same train that's
exactly what they're proposing to do
that and why is there always fighting
about the tracks me the original view of
high-speed rail authority was that they
were going to show up in San Jose with
the bulldozers and they were going to
walk right through the financial or four
tracks elevated right straight in San
Francisco there is no way that we're
going to do that and there isn't the
fridge didn't even try to do that in
their system what they did was they
operate in a blended way a combined way
so that high-speed trains come in and
they mingle with the local trains it
reduces capacity it reduces speed
somewhat but but it reduces
environmental opposition and it reduces
capital costs immensely so that's the
trade-off that's been made yes it makes
it makes eminent sense but there's
another thing to think about and that is
that the San Francisco market may
actually be caltrain to San Jose
changing the high-speed rail rather than
you know transbay terminal 2 2 to LA
there may be much more people than we
even realize now who will take caltrain
a good caltrain
and especially if Bart makes the final
connection to San Jose station then the
real service may not be transbay
terminal 2 l.a it may be collected on on
bart and caltrain to san jose after that
you know you can go whatever speed you
only go jobs what kinds of changes have
they made to achieve a continuous
improvement in efficiency that you
talked about oh my goodness all kinds of
things design of the of the pantograph
so that it's much more aerodynamic
building barriers around it so that's
more or dynamic if you look at the
initial billet trains they have a kind
of a blunt nose if you look at the ones
now it's stretched out for 20 meters of
very narrow very thin nose all kinds of
aerodynamics interestingly enough they
did that almost as much for noise as
they did for for energy because they had
mints problems with high high noise
levels and noise comes from errors that
wind resistance among other things and
from the sound of the pentagram and so
they were able to use the technology to
for a lot of reasons both of those in
that case I thought your comments on
integration with the the other
transportation infrastructure was really
interesting and when I went to a
presentation here for the design
potential design of the Palo Alto High
Speed Rail Station they were kind of
saying now maybe even help us figure out
we're going to put the garage for
thousands of cars I mean I have a can we
still get it do we well but my other
markets that will get it anyhow you know
we have caltrain now and what are we
doing about providing good now speaking
as a resident with everything what are
we doing about providing good access to
our existing mass transit stations not a
hell of a lot if we did you know
caltrain would look very different and
the and the systems might look very
different caltrain is unique in
at one of the very few mass transit
systems i know that has an almost
balanced traffic north sound that is
there almost as many people going south
in the morning as there are going north
and vice versa in the evening so it's
not like it is in New York it makes a
much more economic system and we're not
taking advantage of it instead we're
arguing every year about funding
caltrain and you know they're fighting
this battle time after time the
management of caltrain spends as much
time you know playing local politics and
trying to get money as they do planning
and running the system it's it is they
say a hell of a way to run a railroad
that's all your hand I was wondering
what percentage of phrase carried by air
US persons spread very low very low very
low in Pristina jo tum kaam I'll bet you
that if you look at the value you get
quite a different answer I know that let
me extrapolate a little bit railways
carry about forty percent of the ton
miles trucks carry safe thirty percent
of the ton miles maybe maybe yeah that's
about right and then barges and
pipelines etc but trucks earn ninety
percent of the revenue and railways
earned ten percent of the revenue
another way to put that is that this is
a trick question what would you say
measured by value of cargo what would
you say is the largest port in the
United States
JK court poor JFK a poll of JFK the air
terminal you know international cargo
terminal at JFK handles more cargo value
than any other port in the United sing
and of the top 10 ports three of them
are airports what we want every x value
I do want to step in and say there's
really not any alternative to railways
for moving very heavy raw materials like
rock and you know I grew up in a not too
far away from a phosphate mine so sick
of that long long train where did you
grow up South Georgia oh goodness I grew
up in Central Florida right in the
middle of them okay well as I was on the
north side of it on south side reacts
after you but you know you see these two
mile long trains where it's carload
after carload of raw material you cannot
do that even by troc each of the
transport mode has its own sort of
market what railways in the u.s. do is
or railways around the world in the
freight side is very high volumes mostly
lower value cargo but not always a unit
train and operating in what are called
unit trains that is the train is buckled
together at the beginning and it never
is unbuckled until it gets to the end
one whole unit tray sometimes 10,000
tons sometimes 15,000 tons of coal and
one train another kind of unit train is
double stacked containers yeah that
starts out of the port of La Long Beach
and it ends up in Chicago or even
further east and and it's a whole
hundred car training double stacked
containers who knows what's in there but
it can be done because it starts here
and it ends here and it never stops most
theft on railways occurs in yards you
ever stopped it people will steal things
from it but if you keep it moving
then there's no theft and if you keep it
moving then then although railways can't
really compete with trucks on speed they
can come close close enough but what the
shipper wants is not just speed but
reliability the problem that railways
have had is not just speed but
reliability you know yeah we'll pick it
up sort of today or tomorrow and we'll
get it there whenever we feel like it
trust us and you can do that with coal
or limestone which can't do that with
television sets and so the developing of
the high quality market for railways in
the US has been either containers or a
very interesting innovation the largest
trucking company in the United States JB
Hunt actually moves most of the cargo on
the rowing they rent a train an empty
train from A to B very market all of the
containers rather there's no idea what's
on that train they just bring an empty
train in they they loaded up and they
hold it over here and they pick it up
over here and the railroad is the
wholesaler of transportation capacity
have no idea what's in the train and
they did that for a reason that you
wouldn't expect the reason they did that
is because they couldn't hire drivers
anymore they had trucking companies had
a three hundred percent turnover and
their drivers because it's a miserable
way to make a living you're gone all the
time you're driving all the time it's
uncomfortable JB Hunt means these guys
here live here and they pick up and
deliver here or they pick up and deliver
here but they're home at night so
they're able to have a much Stabler
employment base and everybody's happier
so you know sometimes innovation has
driven by things that we really don't
think about but turn out to be really
important yeah well said other questions
you said something about the cost of per
mile or pretend houses
doesn't always work out for trains I
mean it seems like it feels like a
no-brainer and that's what Germany train
companies to a minute per ton mile in
the United States for railways is about
3 cents so 3 us cents per ton long the
average revenue of a truck now is about
twelve cents pretend mall so if you can
ship it by rail of course you do I've
also seen some ads by i think it was CSX
about how much more environmentally
friendly it is to ship by train as
opposed to shipping by trust true you
know that's true but if i'm a shipper I
don't care how do I care what I want to
know is what I mean and it's the only
way you market can operate you can't
really say to a shipper why don't you
pick an inefficient on economic way of
shipping because it makes me feel better
that is in the way of the market works
but what happens to the railways if a
carbon tax is put in I think and have
argued that carbon tax would be good for
railways but not as good as you think
because even for trucks the cost of fuel
as a percentage of their total operating
costs is really not that high robots
even lower carbon taxes would hit
airlines somewhat but carbon taxes
really won't hit transportation that
hard its power generation that carbon
tax has its major impact on and
industrial uses not the transportation
sector is surprisingly less affected by
a carbon tax than other sectors of the
economy I've got one more question that
I want to ask and she has one oh you've
got one I'm sorry I didn't see you know
pls 4head
I think he loves us but like when the
mercury so slow down air traffic and
made it less appealing is all the
security checks and taking off your
shoes and everything and I remember
there is an incident or a train I wonder
if all that would start happening on
trends as well I mean these checks them
that's a scary question the TSA has four
years indicated that they're not happy
with rail security and that they are
thinking about doing something which
really terrifies people if you take the
the channel tunnel from London to Paris
if you take that train the security to
get on that train is airline like they
actually check people and they verify
that they're not carrying thinking
that's the only one that I know but
there have been terrorist incidents on
trains there was an incident and the
Netherlands some years ago in which
South moluccan Indonesian terrorists
hijacked a train full of passengers and
made them pull them off onto a siding
and then they threaten the game unless
they were their friends were released or
whatever their demands were so it's not
as if it hasn't happened but thus far
we've allowed our trains operated under
much lower security levels and as I said
how many of you would be willing to
arrive at an airport much less than an
hour before the flight is scheduled to
go anybody I wouldn't maybe even a
little more but I'll walk into a train
station with 10 minutes to go knowing
that I'm going to be fine so that's 50
minutes 50 minutes is a major part of a
300-mile trip it's a it's a big factor
it's not much if you're flying from San
Francisco to New York what if you're
flying from San Francisco you're taking
a train from or flying from San
Francisco to LA it's a big it's only an
hour in ten minute trip in the air
so that the airport security and other
stuff almost doubles the link in the
trip now as I said that gets evened out
on a 3,000 mile trip but not on a
200-mile trip or 300-mile trip
conversely if we ever get to a system of
trusted travelers let's say whereby if
you have a badge you know they checked
you out there sure you're nice and
you're not going are causing problems
and you can walk straight through a gate
onto an airplane it might change the
competitive situation fairly significant
simple technology I think it's just that
we're now looking at the problem that
way and actually there's an even simpler
way just put more inspectors just you
know put 20 times 10 times as many
inspectors or five times as many
inspectors so that they don't have long
lines and more important you don't have
the variability it's it isn't even the
predicted time if I knew it was always
going to be 10 minutes from the time i
get to the line till that time you know
i get through the other side i can
factor that it but i don't even know
that and I'm obsessive so I you know
well if it could be Tim but it could be
30 so I better allow 45 just the way
people plan I do
so if there's no other questions I've
got one final question porting them a
couple of comments to everybody oh so
I'm kind of a train fan always have me
too and I'm curious how do you feel is
there something we can do in the u.s. to
kind of improve the sort of interest in
trains but people would have what would
your recommendations be going forward
well you know when I showed eight
billion Japanese passengers yeah okay
they know trains everybody in Japan is
ridden a train many times local trains
high-speed trains whatever but they're
familiar with trends most Americans have
never taken a train certainly haven't
taken them very often and certainly
their experience in many cases is not
such as the cost to do it again so the
first the issue in the United States is
just to have more good service that
people use and are used to and
understand what it is and how to use it
and what the barriers in the end the way
the system operates are and we just we
don't have that yeah and starting from
there the second thing would be I think
just make it easier to use the train
system start from the good business side
I always look at the question yeah yeah
so I want to thank everybody for coming
to these one more point to people who've
registered for credit the course
evaluations are available online now
remember you're evaluating me you're
evaluating the choice of people for the
series you're evaluating whether it was
a good set of things that happened
you're not directly evaluating the
individual speakers presentations only
insofar as you know we got the right
people to to do the presenting and we
presented the right kind of topics okay
so I do look forward to reading your
comments on that look forward to reading
your final comments for the last
sessions we wouldn't have these series
if it weren't for great audiences
and I really appreciate everybody coming
and supporting us by being here Thanks
to everyone and please join me in
thanking Lou today my address is on the
opening slide you have the slides I
don't mind people sending emails saying
what's the answer to this question I
don't bother me at all so please do that
half the value in these sessions is to
follow up not the session yes we'll have
the slides up in the next few days
Thanks everything
you